Okay,
we are alive.
Today started with um 4:00 a.m. smoke
detector in my ear. So, I'm half asleep
today, but the release is done. And uh
so far it seems like not everything is
on fire. So that's pretty good.
Let me uh pull up we've been doing
lately.
Welcome
Madermer.
Welcome.
So, uh, I've released a few different
things here. Almost at 500 on the
release, which I would say is decent.
Half of what I was hoping for, but
decent.
36,000 views.
And then we've got uh this new article
that I just posted.
So, if you're interested in some of the
technical details of our release,
few of them are right here.
So, um I think here's the plan for
today.
We're going to just do a little bit of
stuff on meta.
Uh I've got articles to like polish up
and release all week. I did push the
Docker build, so if you want the Docker,
that is now available.
Uh, and other than that, yeah, I think
we're just going to see what we can do
on meta since the goals for the next
couple weeks are to gain a fair bit of
traction on 300. Just like tell everyone
about all the stuff we've built, fix
some stuff for the meta guys cuz they
have an RLM that really should work by
now, but we'll help them out.
And then, um,
yeah, the tactical like massive multi-
aent battle sim. Those are all the
things we're going to be building.
This is going to be a pretty easy week,
though. I'm not going to push too hard.
I'm not going to work crazy hours this
week. Uh we're going to consider this
sort of transition phase between the Rio
release and whatever I start working on
next to be just that, transition phase.
So hopefully we make meta have some
really nice policies. We launch some
cool experiments. We clean up some stuff
on 3 0. Maybe we make some cool stuff
with drones. And then we're getting into
more probably this is probably going to
be like the heavy industry arc, frankly,
in which um
Puffer's got to grow as a company,
right? So we got to build more
interesting like industry side that are
not just games.
Okay, so let's talk about metup. So,
first of all, I accidentally deleted my
Docker container like a goober
in the process of uploading the uh the
other one.
And this time we're going to follow
their instructions exactly.
And we're going to see uh what happens
when we do that.
I think it's probably just going to
break everything,
but we shall see.
Yeah, there it's downloading some jank
version of PieTorch.
Can we just like
Good day. Welcome, Finn.
How's it going?
I don't like that this is pinning torch
man.
Now what we do is
we attempt to render the model.
You need to install the node version
manager in order to install the node
package manager. Wow.
We're going to very much limit the
amount that I have to interact with
this.
Interacting with web programmers in
general, like I you just you get
stupider by the minute. I swear
you just get dumber by the minute.
Web is easy. Yeah, it's very easy when
you just write HTML and CSS. Uh it's a
total pain in the ass when you look at
modern web stacks. It's awful.
I literally just like open any of the
modern JavaScript frameworks and uh I
mean you don't even have to open the
framework. Just the fact that you
install a version manager to install a
package manager is insane. Already,
you've already lost.
Okay.
Does just do this.
Where are you coming from? Most easiest
things.
Uh I'm coming from a perspective of
writing very complicated things and
making them very simple and really not
liking when people take very simple
things and very and make them very
complicated.
Yeah, because RL is much harder than
webdev. Like just fundamentally on an
algorithmic level, like it is a hard
thing. Um, but if you look at the code
that we write to like do
state-of-the-art reinforcement learning,
our code is simpler and easier to read
and follow than like any basic tutorial
on modern web development.
Now the things that will you'll run into
uh with difficulty on RL are not even
problems with like the aren't problems
with the code, right? It's problems with
like fundamental learning dynamics and
stuff. That stuff is hard, but that's
very different from like the code is
more complicated than it needs to
It's possible to show us how you start
working
how you start working with target square
end. What do you mean
It trains in 20 seconds,
25 seconds, whatever.
You can track this on Neptune or wand by
just adding d- Neptune or d-w.
There's training. That puffer train
command does the exact same thing as
just running pufferlib
pufferlib.pufferl.
So it's just running that script.
There's no magic at all.
Puffer eval target load model path
latest. This is also on the docs. Like
if you look at the cheat sheet, this is
in the docs.
And then there you go. There are your
puffers.
how you train a very new custom
environment the exact same way. So if
you follow the target tutorial, it shows
you how to set up your own environment
and then that like that same training
command, that same setup, like
everything works there. And there's even
like a checklist of things that can go
wrong. So if you tell me like what like
where you are in building a new
environment and like what is confusing,
I will help and possibly even update the
docs for you. Hey Brad, how's it going?
Have you looked into active inference
and free energy principle before?
Nope, not at all.
I do I'm vaguely aware though that there
are like
there are like separate communities that
have kind of framed different they've
kind of say framed the same problems in
different ways in RL and like in
decision-m in general. So I don't know
how much overlap there is versus like
how many things are the same versus uh
the same with different words versus
actually being different things.
the way we have things now in RL, not in
RL literature, that's a mess. But if you
look at the way that we have things now,
how we do RL and puffer liib, it's very
simple.
It's like very, very simple.
Yeah, let's see if we can I'm what I'm
trying to do at the moment for reference
here to people is um we've got this RL
environment.
It looks like this. This is from this is
third party. This is from uh the meta
guys.
And they've got this like factory-esque
environment here.
And uh basically we have we have models
that are at least as good as theirs and
train faster, but nobody has good models
on this. And I trained really good
models on a previous version of this
environment. So something's broken and I
want to figure out why for them. Uh but
the problem is I can't really run their
training code. I can't really run their
renderer. So, I'm kind of blind at the
moment and I'm trying to figure out how
to deal with that. So, if we can at
least get like the playable version of
this to run.
What do you think
we have to do to reach AGI?
We need to get rid of episodic training,
etc.
Um, not really. It's not like episodes
or the problem or like any it's just
complexity in general, right? We need to
scale this stuff to more complex and
interesting environments and the
algorithmic changes that we make along
the way need to be motivated by a
combination of like very carefully
designed probe environments in which we
isolate each potential thing that's
wrong with an algorithm and then also
just like actual learning at scale on
complex tasks. Uh and by scale I
actually I mostly mean data scale. Uh a
really big problem with RL was just
everything is so slow you couldn't do
research without thousands of GPUs. That
is now fixed with Puffer. Uh we can do
research very very fast. So there's
algorithms work to be done. You know
there's uh there's simulator work to be
done. Uh the road ahead is actually
fairly clear though now. Whereas before
it was just kind of a mess. Now stuff is
pretty sane and stable and RL is like no
longer cursed. RL is just a field that
needs progress on it now. Before it was
like we have no idea what to do. Nothing
works. All the papers are wrong. Now at
least we have a basis for making
progress.
Was it that slow? Yes, Puffer Lib is
literally more than a thousand times
faster than everything else.
I like that seems like a joke or an
exaggeration, but it's not.
We trained puffer lib for 10 I mean for
30. We have a training run on one pabyte
of observations. That is more than 20
times the amount of data used for
training all of GPT4 and we did that on
one server that is sitting right behind
me over there.
Do we need better reward specific? I
mean, there are a lot of things we
potentially need. You can read actually
I released an article today about what
we did on the algorithm side for 3
that's on X.
But um
there's like some technique stuff on how
to better define observations and
rewards, but I think a lot of it is
going to be like sane uh sane algorithm
work. I would think like there's
actually quite a bit to do on the
algorithm side and the thing is like the
algorithm side was very very heavily
explored in RL research. There are
hundreds and hundreds of papers but all
the experiments sucked. So like we
literally don't know if any of that
stuff works. Uh that was the issue. So
it's not necessarily that like oh it's
already all been tried. I think it's the
problem is just like nobody actually
carefully controlled anything and uh all
the results are just invalid.
How did you get such a huge improvement?
We rewrote the entire RL stack from the
ground up.
That's what we did. We have our own
vectorzation for parallel simulation. We
have our own optimized environment
format. All our environments are C and
use that. We have our own C API to make
it easier to write that. We have like 25
different environments now where like
we've gone through the process of making
it really really fast and easy and
simple to make tons of different types
of sims. Um we have our own trainer
where like we rewrote all that from the
ground up. I it's literally you had to
just redo the whole field.
I mean, I've this has been like I've
been working way harder than I worked in
my PhD over this. And uh it's been a bit
over a year of just like really working
on this to make this happen.
And that was a year that's like
basically been informed by seven years
of being an RL and seeing what the field
was like and trying to push the envelope
in academia before that.
Do you have any thought on adaptive
clip?
Adaptive clip po.
let me check for you real quick.
I think I do have thoughts. This is
probably the best one that the best set
of experiments to use for you.
Let me see if I find it.
We'll give you thoughts informed by like
actually good data
instead of just me guessing.
yeah. So, I'm pretty sure, and it
depends on your environment, but like I
don't think that you actually get that
much out of adaptive like adaptive
clipping coefficient. I think that the
main thing is that you need to have some
clipping because otherwise you corrupt
the policy. Uh, and the amount that you
have to be careful with that depends on
the environment and other settings, but
like
on some like on our harder environments
like anything from 02 to 6ish was kind
of fine.
There's not like a very sharp peak I
would say where it's like, oh yeah, it
has to be almost exactly 02 or something
like that or like it could change over
the course of training. Um, I don't
think that there's too much in that
parameter specifically you have to worry
about.
Let me see. Is there a parameter where
I mean honestly stuff like the Atom
betas which are like sharper could even
be a reason for that. Or actually the
one that's really important if you want
adaptive anything it's adaptive gamma.
All right, adaptive gamma or like better
yet some way to replace generalized
advantage estimation with something that
automatically adapts would be way way
way better.
Self-organizing approaches. Um, so stuff
that's like genetics inspired has
traditionally been really bad and uh
yeah, it just has not worked at all. Uh,
but I think with Puffer now it could
kind of work. you'd at least get
something interesting. And the reason is
that we can train like genetic stuff. We
should absolutely be able to train 10
million plus steps per second.
So when you can do that, like we could
probably do something like simulate a
100,000 years worth of experience or
something and then you should actually
be able to get some cool stuff out of
it.
Um, the Rich Richard Sutton's the stuff
he's doing at Keen at the moment. I
don't know what he's doing. Like the
like the Atari robot, like the robot
controlling Atari stuff is pretty
diametrically opposed from what I do and
how I think that RL's going to be
advanced. Um, yeah,
defining their own step sizes when uh
that's kind of done implicitly.
So if you look at any of the optimizer
work like we have muon added in that's
kind of what you're doing
like you're using like you're using like
uh very loose curvature estimates right
to adjust step size.
So I don't think that you need like the
agent sets its own step. That's like
part of the optimizer basically and I
don't think it's specific to RL. It's
just generally good. And that's in the
article as well. Like Muan was a big
part of uh of 3, like changing our
optimizer to muon.
Does anybody know how to make WebGPU
work on Linux?
What is the chance that this link is
just invalid AI garbage?
Oh, it works.
Cool.
Well, it had to relaunch my chat, so I
missed anything that was done in the
last few seconds.
Have a think if we can generalize other
params. Yeah, Finn. The big one right
now, the one that I'm telling you is
like legitimately a big problem in RL is
the gamma lambda in uh generalized
advantage estimation. And gamma is way a
bigger of a problem than lambda. Uh
that's adaptive horizon is what you
need, not adaptive clipping.
All right. And like the way that gamma
does credit assignment, like
it's like obviously really bad, but
empirically it's really hard to beat.
That's the issue with it.
Firefox does not support
web GPU.
The heck?
Uh there's just there's a viewer that I
need to load. Captain,
Google Chrome unstable not found.
I have to do Google Chrome dev.
Is it just Google Chrome- unstable or
thing.
Okay.
So this is um
you ever considered tackling arc AGI
challenge? Uh, it's like again it's like
diametrically opposed from what I'm
doing. You can't learn to solve those
challenges from scratch. They basically
rely on your built-in pattern
recognition from like all of your
experience elsewhere. Like you can't
learn that type of stuff from scratch.
But like my stuff solves problems that
these LLMs fail hilariously badly at. So
like
they're just very different directions.
Does this work
thing?
Yeah. No. Stuff is just not working at
all.
So obnoxious.
super slow, but it works.
Okay, so this doesn't work.
Uh, I'm trying to think what I do about
this.
Out of curiosity, would you think
pursuing a PhD is worth it? Now,
uh, I only suggest that people who know
that they want to do a PhD do a PhD.
That's generally my recommendation.
the people who should do a PhD it's
because that you know that you want to
do a PhD like in my case uh it was I had
a thing that was going to take five
years to work on and uh it kind of
enabled all the tech with puffer liib
there's still a whole bunch of annoying
academic friction even in the best cases
like MIT was the best place I could have
done for this I had a very supportive
adviser and there's still just a bunch
of pain in the ass stuff in academia
pretty much you do a PhD if you want if
you know you want to do a PhD
uh how do you support yourself doing
open research nowadays? Puffer is a
company. We have clients. All our
stuff's free and open source, but uh
people can either pay us for specific
things that they want done in
reinforcement learning or if they are
doing reinforcement learning themselves,
want to use our tools and want
assistance with that or they want custom
features etc. Uh they can pay us for
that.
Inspired to still pursue research.
Inspire that you still pursue research
for your own causes. makes me want to do
the same thing. Yeah. I mean, this is
just like this is tech that just has to
exist pretty much and nobody's going to
build it if I don't. The proof of that
is in how like how much ludicrously
faster Puffer is than everything else.
Like you should not be able to just like
build a small open- source thing and
make something a thousand times faster
than what is out there and like also
perform better. That's just not a thing
that should happen. there should not be
room for a thousandfold improvement in
like anything that anybody has tried. Uh
but there is. So it kind of just shows
you how bad the state of the field was.
And I saw the potential of what RL could
do with like open AI5 and Alpha Star and
Go and all those results back in 2019.
And uh it this just had to work. This
had to be made to work. We couldn't just
forget about RL because we're going to
pay for it. Like this is going to be a
key piece of so so so much tech in the
future. I can see it and uh this is the
way that we have to make it work. We're
not just going to wait around for OpenAI
and DeepMind and whoever else to decide
that they want to do RL again and throw
billions of dollars at it, right? We're
going to just do it in our garages.
I only see it to provide value for the
top research lab. I would agree. Uh if
you're an ambitious person, I it is only
worth doing a PhD in one of the top
labs. I agree. I mean, I could say the
same about university, but whatever.
I want to pursue research independently.
I love to collab with other researchers
and ideas. Academ can be discouraging of
this open mindset, I guess. Yes, that is
true. That's why I'm doing all this
stuff open source and puffer, right? So,
this is the place to do open source RL.
PhD graduates are rolling out like
crazy. The value of it does not hold as
much weight as it used to. Um,
I mean it's it's not that it's not
valuable, it's that it's five years of
your life and like you know if you
graduate college at 22, you're 27 by the
time you finish your PhD
and like a lot of that time is just not
going to be very fun.
AI advancements also discourage me. It
is tougher now. It depends on the field.
If you go like to do a PhD to work on
language models, uh, and you're not at
like one of the very few labs that has
access to like actual industry scale
hardware partnerships, you're not going
to have a good time.
I'm 15 and interested in cyber sec. What
should I focus on? You should learn uh
you should learn like basic low-level
dev is what I would say. like build some
cool stuff and see and then learn some
uh learn some cyber sec from there like
bas like system like just basic system
stuff will go a long way
you need to know like quite a bit of uh
it's actually it doesn't overlap a ton
with the type of stuff I do but you kind
of need to know like a lot of system
stuff and like Um,
a lot of exploiting stuff is knowing a
lot about uh actually I'm not even going
to I'm not a cyber sec person. Like I've
done a tiny amount of stuff in that
space like barely. I will say that there
was I think that the lectures are still
online. There's like a University
Florida class on that uh where the
lectures I think are still on YouTube.
That was pretty good. Um, yeah, that's
about all I got for you in
Can I make this thing not use web GPU
somehow?
Oh, this has to not be on the docker.
Okay.
made a PR which fixes the speed of drone
on web.
That sounds useful.
Does it break it on desktop? Did you
check?
do a quick merge for you
and get on to the website later.
135 lines to uh
Oh, I didn't see you were using time.
RNG. Yeah, that's fine then. What the
heck is this?
Maybe Per should have a clang format. I
I don't like to enforce formatterers.
It's like you either see the way the
code is written and you try to do
something vaguely similar or you don't
I like how your ring buffer is a ring
buffer.
You made a buffer for rings. That is a
ring buffer.
So most of this is for just format
changes and then it's the one mcript and
thing.
Thank you.
Hey, there we go. Works on Firefox
Nightly.
Please drop a replay file here to see a
replay.
not going to be busty because I can't
freaking bench, man.
I haven't been able to bench in like
three weeks because of the shoulder.
Hopefully next week we go back at least
to a plate.
building an MVP for stable diffusion
stuff. Bench me
before the shoulder injury. I could
bench uh I believe 210 for 10 and then
my best was uh my best single was a 265.
I'm very much looking forward to getting
back to training, but I have to be a
little more careful this time.
Curious if you're excited about
imitation learning, which seems popular,
robotics, or is it all all the way? Um,
it's like
it clearly doesn't get you everything
and it's also just like not a difficult
or interesting problem.
So
it doesn't do too much for me really.
Gimitation learning is kind of just easy
and like also it's not going to like
you're stuck to the data that you have
is the issue with it, right? Like if you
want to go out and collect new data,
imitation learning doesn't do that for
you.
Did I like I didn't paste this in wrong.
Yeah.
Why do you think it's so popular in
robotics? Um cuz RL's hard and like for
certain problems like they can just
collect a ton of data.
I mean it doesn't work for everything
though clearly, right?
Like if I want to train um like my drone
environment or something that has like
lower volume of data, what makes more
sense? Trying to like go collect like go
run a million drones around and collect
data forever or like writing a few
hundred line simulation.
Uh, it's faster if you disentangle it.
End to end is not bad. It's just you
have to have more compute.
Technically, end to end should be better
overall
working for Tesla right now for
instance. So, I don't know if they're
doing strict RL or imitation. Uh,
probably mostly imitation.
Can you leave some documents in
description in YouTube?
when I watch the video next day, I don't
know what you're talking. So, the
problem with that is that I have I have
VODs on X, YouTube, and Twitch, and
there's no way to automatically label
them. And there's also not like one
topic per stream. It's just I stream all
of my development, right? Um, I am going
to probably start doing like some sort
of highlights or something. We'll see.
But, uh, if you want GitHub repo, paper,
and all that, that's always the same.
So, we have everything that you need at
just puffer.ai.
The GitHub, we have our Discord, we have
X, we have our docs, we have all our
environments. It's all at puffer.ai. AI.
Do you think robotics
will eventually explore what they can
do?
I think they'll probably have to. I
don't see how you get enough uh
imitation learning data to do everything
without collecting new stuff
there. It might technically be possible
to do like this infinite bootstrapping
thing. Uh I don't know. I It seems
difficult.
your RL robotics company.
I'm not super interested in just doing
like one specific app of robotics uh as
a company and just like doing that,
right? I want to make this tech stable,
mature, and like I really want to just
push RL as a whole as far as I possibly
can. And then on the application side,
we'll basically just be looking for
wherever we think that RC can really uh
make a big difference in a specific area
and get us, you know, a good chunk of
revenue so that we can keep scaling up
our research efforts.
Off the top of your head, what is an
environment that you want in ocean? Oh,
okay. Let me actually do stuff like like
let let me think of something for you
here. Um,
cuz there actually there are a few
simple things.
Okay, this one's I have one that's
really simple. Let me think next.
Okay, this is something really basic.
Um, but this would actually be helpful
for research. And if you're interested
in contributing to contributing to
research, this would be like a really
nice first step. Uh, making an basically
take my convert environment, which just
has all the puffers going to different
goals. Okay.
And, uh, just make the target spawn at a
fixed radius from the center of the
screen.
Make that radius configurable through
Python. So you can make it like wider or
shallower. Um, and then have it have the
option to either put them at like fixed
angle intervals so they're evenly spaced
in a circle around you or like randomly
place them at that same fixed radius.
The point of this is going to be we
basically we want to see if you train
models if like the model is just going
to always learn to go to the same target
um or if it if we can like get an
algorithm that will naturally
incentivize you to go to all the
different options.
Uh and this is going to be used for
there's like this diversity is all you
need paper thing that we were trying to
replicate and we needed like a basic
environment like this. So that would be
like one probe environment and then I
think generally we have like there's
several of these that we would like to
have which are like environments devoted
to testing a specific interaction or a
specific known quirk of uh learning
algorithms.
If you're looking for like cooler larger
things then we can also talk about that.
Um there are cooler larger things we can
do as well.
Congrats on the big release. Thank you.
If I Well, let me see if I understand.
Put targets to reach in a ring at fixed
radius either fixed angle spacing or
random. Yep. And then make the radius
like things that you could set from
Python should be like the number of
targets. um the radius and then whether
or not they're fixed spacing like always
the same order for the same color target
or randomized.
In fact, to make it simpler, instead of
randomizing the position, you can just
have the flag randomize the order. That
might even be better. So then we'd see
if it's if they always go to the same
target or they always go to the same
position like Yeah, we could see that
like that would be better. Yeah, do
that.
And yeah, thanks Tim. It's been a lot of
work.
I'm wanting to see something like multi-
aent agur.io. Uh yeah, don't do that
one. Um I asked Makado for his who like
did the aggio. He went and he made an
end like that. I asked for his blessing
to like port it to a package and we had
a kind of an odd discussion and uh yeah
he doesn't want to see it as a puffer
end which is kind of bad but whatever
like we don't really need it anyways.
I mean it it kind of depends what you're
interested in, right? Like the thing is
games are always nice for benchmarks. Uh
probe environments are very useful if
they're welldesigned for research.
It's very it's even more useful if you
can like go actually conduct research
using said probe environment, right?
Like that's actually contribution to
algorithm core which is really awesome.
Um,
industry adjacent stuff is also good.
Like, you know, think of like the big
application areas in industry. Having
more Sims in that area is useful for us
and that actually generates us uh
opportunities to like go into industry.
And of course, if you build a SIM and we
find something in that space, we'll
bring you on for that as well. Um,
yeah, there like a few different ways
you can contribute effectively.
This thing doesn't have a setup.py Pi or
a Pi project tol.
We kind of have to make this work
though. Um, I have a message thread on
the other monitor here with the author
of this. I'll set up build. Okay.
activate this
Crazy.
sink this bloody thing again.
No, I shouldn't have to sink it again.
Let's just do
fresh clone.
And if we do this on Firefox nightly of
all places,
So weird.
I have the right URL, don't I? It's uh
the port. I mean,
yeah, just it goes to 27, which is the
same thing.
everything. But there's one missing
icon. No big deal.
So weird.
How's that even possible?
Okay. Okay. So, there's some weird
websocket thing.
fun? Simply
no fun at all.
We actually we're getting a little bit
of traction on the article for something
nice and technical is good. Pretty cool
All right. Apparently, this is getting
fixed right now.
We can start looking at a little bit of
their code in the meanwhile cuz
something is horribly horribly wrong
with it.
I'm trying to think what we where we
even start though. It's like there's so
much stuff now.
Now there is so much stuff
Enough.
comment out the exit.
Okay.
I just add S to this.
Ow.
Do I make the targets move in a circle
or fix them in place? Just fix them in
place.
sent you an image on Discord. Yeah. One
second.
Let me finish just going absolutely
insane over this garbage.
you man.
Okay,
these all work and these are fine,
right? And then
if I grab this thing.
need this image and then we will figure
out what's this end is doing.
This thing's lagging my whole PC,
though.
Perfect.
Uh, can you spawn all the puffers in the
center?
If you spawn all the puffers in the
center and train it, you should see them
all going to a target.
Basically, what I'm trying to figure
out, and we're probably going to have to
make them like all the same color or
something.
what we're basically trying to figure
out to give you the idea here.
Let's say that there are like a bunch of
different easily reachable goals,
right? So like you could essentially you
can get you can get a reward by going to
one of many goals. RL will tend to like
send all the agents to the first goal it
happens to find and then it won't ever
find any of the other ones. So we
basically we want to play with that a
little bit.
Okay, be right back. I'm going use a
restroom real quick and then we will
figure out how this environment works.
I'll hook this up to hopefully print out
rewards and uh yeah, we'll go from
there. I'll be right back though.
That's okay.
I will just suffer for the next couple
of hours without any more coffee.
You know, one of the things I've
noticed, I've been on like probably the
most consistent healthy schedule I've
been on in quite a while with exercise
and food and sleep and everything. And
um it works great, but when something
gets thrown off, it's like awful.
So, fire alarm or smoke detector, I
mean, woke me up at 4 in the morning. I
had to go to the other building because
it wouldn't shut up. Um,
and yeah, I just feel freaking exhausted
today.
That's okay.
All right.
So,
Lab red
temple.
you mind building and pushing drone?
Yeah. One second then.
the heck.
What's wrong with this?
It looks good locally. Let's see on the
web.
Okay, there is your uh your push.
Enjoy.
Be live in a minute or two.
Okay, that should give me some reward,
right?
What ends up happening is I can't it
won't cache my credentials because I do
all my dev directly in Docker. So every
time I make a new Docker container, it
forgets, you know, doesn't cache
anymore.
I mean, technically, I could just put my
public key on the base
and I could just do it that way. That
would probably be slightly better.
Oh, do they?
That would probably work.
I think it'll like make a million
different connections for me though is
the thing. It'll just like generate a
bajillion OOTH tokens.
cannot train it cuz I messed up my GPU
credentials.
You will literally be able to train that
in CPU on in like a minute.
You should be able to train that thing
super fast.
But thank you. I will actually be using
that.
I have a contributor who'd be interested
in that as well.
Oops.
I probably missed messages here. Yep.
Hang on.
So, apparently
what you're supposed to do with this
thing,
you're supposed to like go over to
I guess this is a mine.
They're going to be so mad if this is
what it is.
If it's literally just like help me
troubleshoot getting their game to build
for half the day and then I play it for
five minutes, I'm like, well, the game
doesn't work.
Uh, that's how it goes most of the time,
though.
Ah, I have to there's a second step.
Okay.
So, now something should happen,
right?
Okay. So, it made a heart.
Yeah.
Then what should happen is I get big
reward.
Let's do this.
Let's uh let's fix their thing. What do
you say?
What is so damn laggy? Is it this thing?
It is this thing.
Let's leave it like this to start. Then
what we'll do?
Uh maybe we'll just do like this, you
know.
She don't
Basically,
well,
you'll see what I do for my analysis in
a bit, but this will be a if provided I
actually can do this, you know, this
will be a really nice uh example use for
how I do my RL work.
This is rare knowledge on how to debug
horribly cursed and overbuilt systems.
It's not the exciting content, but it is
the valuable content.
here's our
current run on meta
of this run.
one battery.
There are initially two generators and
10 mines on the map.
Definitely need to be able to dump
replays.
Okay, so they start picking up some ore
and then they like stop just they just
stop doing that.
Can we get like multiple of these
metrics?
Make like a meta
meta meta dashboard. E
Okay.
Red or
We've got hearts. Got red ore. Got red
batteries.
Red batteries.
Uh, this does actually go up nice and
steady over time.
Four goes to here.
This heart game thing crashed.
I'm read Am I reading that right?
Yeah, this crashed.
Oh, this is with all the the cool down
zeroed as well.
Yeah, that's interesting.
So, this should be super easy. And it's
getting
it's getting reward from somewhere.
Looks like you can build really fast
drones for 200 bucks.
So, I am thinking about um like form
factors. I don't know how interesting
that is to you guys. And I don't know
how like actually producing hardware at
scale is quite difficult if we want to
go that route. Um but that would
basically guarantee us that uh we do
something valuable enough that we never
need to worry about research funding
again and everybody involved would be
very happy. Um because basically like if
you got like a a decent form factor
that's more agile than a quadcopter.
Like you just control it with cracked
out RL and it would just be insane.
Actually, I literally saw a thing on X
where China has like mosquito drones now
which are horrifying. So I don't know.
Maybe we build some like what what eats
mosquitoes that's fast? Hummingbirds.
Maybe hummingbirds eat mosquitoes. I
don't know. They probably don't. We'll
come up with something.
Small racing drums.
Yeah. Are there any like reasonable
things I can just buy that will have um
like the API connectivity is important,
right?
If there's like a $500 drone or
whatever, I can like
like I can like send you guys one, send
Spencer one, and buy one for myself, and
then we can just try stuff.
How will you know when your work is
done? What is the end goal? we're going
to make RL really, really, really good.
And then my hope is that that's going to
be very important for long-term general
intelligence. Um,
and if it isn't, then we'll figure out
what else to do. But at the very least,
we're going to have really, really good
reinforcement learning in a very wide
variety of domains. It's going to be
directly useful, and we're going to
apply it in a a bunch of different
domains, and then we'll go from there.
Hummingbird would be a cool prototype
name. Yeah.
research parts. Yeah. I So, the thing is
like I don't really care about like
saving a couple hundred bucks and like
making you guys do a bunch of soldering.
That's kind of dumb. Um
the like parts thing like building your
own stuff would be if we want to explore
different form factors basically
and then that would be super cool.
My hope is we can at least um
at least get like some like basic small
thing signed and then that'll be enough
that I can like at least be send you
guys a stipend or whatever for this
stuff and then if we land something
bigger here. We can uh figure out
something bigger
cuz you guys are doing really good work
on the uh the drone end and uh you know
I want to make sure you get some value
out of it.
across the pond if we need any inerson
jobs.
That'd be cool.
We'll have to set up something big for
that, right? Like we got so we basically
the way puffer works, right? Puffer is
not VC funded. So I have some money that
I can fund small stuff with, but then
bigger stuff is gota be essentially
directly tied to revenue, right? If we
get something signed where a client is
paying us to do stuff, then I can
actually bring people on full-time or
for internships or whatever. and that
can be larger.
The upside to this is I don't have VCs
breathing down my neck constantly, so I
actually get to be involved with all the
cool tech.
No VCs is the strate. Yeah. I mean, it's
just like look, if I were if I had to
deal with VCs, I would have collectively
probably spent several months raising
money, not building stuff by now. I'd
have to be reporting to these [ __ ]
who like don't want you to open source
stuff or like want you to work on dumb
stuff that's like not going to matter or
like whatever. It's just it's not a fun
time. It's like for science side stuff
especially like this. It's just not a
fun time.
I know you want it on LinkedIn. I got to
I got to do it. I know.
Honestly, our most successful stuff,
like we've mostly just been doing cold
outreach at the moment and it like it
works pretty well because like our RL
stuff is getting to be decently well
known and like just the credentials are
kind of enough if people don't know any
RL stuff to at least get you a meeting
and then when they see our tech, they're
pretty darn happy and then they want to
follow up. Like we've had a bunch of
meetings. It's just about finding like
good problem fits.
Man, they're doing something screwy
here, I'm sure.
So this should not get any reward and if
it does something is
It's cool to see that this like more
technical article is doing kind of
decently as well.
Okay. So,
we can confidently say
this thing is not doing anything, which
is good in this case.
See, there's a little bit of red
battery, a little bit of red ore, bit of
heart gained, and nothing, which is
good. But it should be
Now, can they learn to gather lots of
ore?
Very interesting questions that we
answer here.
Low runs.
Ward goes up.
Word goes up nice and quick.
This should go up a lot because it
basically can just spam the button and
keep getting more reward. So, if it
can't do this, it is very dumb.
Yeah, this should just keep going
straight up for basically the whole
episode.
Once it gets to above uh what's that 22
or whatever? 24,
we'll know there isn't some weird cap.
Oh, is there some weird cap?
Huh?
I think there's a weird cap.
Probably the inventory size, right?
I'll use the restroom and then we will
be figuring out that what this is. It's
very convinced this is all the ore you
can get.
Okay, there's definitely some sort of
fundamental limit here.
This is a trivial trivial task.
I bet it's the inventory size, right?
We'll double check, but I bet that's
what it is. So, this or this like
metrics probably just scaled wrong.
Okay, so this worked immediately.
So this is scaled wrong
by 24 maybe.
Not quite.
But this red ore thing
We can see here we get 45
reward. So this sum
is the correct thing.
And the reason for this by the way is
0.5 times 100
item max. You can get up to 50 items.
We're very close to that. Let me see.
I think technically it starts out with a
couple in it inventory.
can we just do this
and have it get hearts?
Simple question.
Oh, interestingly, it was kind of
starting to like learn, I guess, to get
rid of hearts
or to use hearts, I guess, to get rid of
inventory items, maybe.
I mean hopefully for the folks watching
you get the general gist of what I'm
trying to do here. I'm kind of sleepy
today, but let me just sort of explain,
right? We have this hideously
complicated environment where like I
think that RL should solve it very
easily. And in fact, I have solved it
with uh earlier versions of puffer lib
on earlier versions of the environment,
but somehow they've like some stuff is
just broken and it's not working
correctly. So, uh there essentially
there are a bunch of intermediate
objectives
and they kind of just have them all
thrown together. So, I'm changing it so
that it only rewards for like the first
really easy objective and then what if
we just reward for the last objective.
So, like can it figure out everything
end to end? I'm trying basic little
stuff like this and I'm making sure that
the uh expected rewards that we should
be getting match up with the metrics and
they only seem to match up with this
rewards.mme. They don't actually match
the uh the other ones. So, I think the
other ones are scaled wrong and we have
to go off of this reward mean. And then
basically we see from here
we see from here whether training is
still stuck in the same spot as before.
the reward mean metric is stuck, but the
heart get metric goes up.
These all like just stop collecting ore,
right?
This goes up and then it goes back down.
This goes the batteries keep going up
but only to like 35 or whatever.
probably doing some like very locally
optimal thing.
We should probably just get the policy
renderer working now.
We'll do that next.
Okay. 32ish
hearts. Not very good.
You done taking forever?
No.
this actually run or do they just break
my stuff
Like with the mechanics that are in this
environment now, I could literally
reimplement this thing in less than a
thousand lines. have it train like three
million plus steps per second and it
would be fine.
I have to pull latest meta. So,
literally all this does is make my life
harder.
See what's in here.
Right. Replay.
We back.
Oh, yeah. It's literally just the web
app. It just I guess it eats all your
memory and dies. Very cool.
Hopefully stream is good
like it
Okay, it's just a compressed file.
That's fine.
So, we'll just do
puffer tank docker
and uh
replay
Dream good as always. How's it going,
man? Hey, how you doing?
We're debugging crazy environment things
on a very difficult to figure out code.
Okay,
I was
Dang it. Now the mic is picking up my
typing since I moved it. Right, I'll
have to fix that. My bad.
I'm not liking how locked up my system
is.
Like what is it that's running on this?
Nothing.
There's like some ghost stuff here. I
don't know. Weird.
It's definitely something with the meta
stuff though. Like I don't know what it
is that like the system is always super
fast.
Something with meta is just like screwed
it up.
probably some it's probably these tabs
or something are just like
get rid of all this crap. No,
they're probably like eating a bunch of
memory and not showing somehow.
There we go.
Hopefully this thing doesn't
eat all the memory and die again.
Guess
that works.
And now I need the other command.
cool. That'd be Yeah, that's like That's
super cool.
That's pretty high up there in the uh
priorities as well. Oops. Turn the
volume down just a little bit. Let me
know if that's still too loud or too
quiet or what.
Uh, this needs specific web socket,
doesn't it?
going to drive me crazy. this like
gankualization
Oh, okay. I'm dumb. That's why. Cool.
Close this.
over here so I don't do that again.
How the hell is this thing supposed to
work?
How you doing? I hope you're all good.
This environment is driving me bonkers,
man. Is what's going on. I guess for now
I'll just go back to like freaking
trying experiments blind cuz this
renderer does not work for [ __ ]
It just doesn't work.
And none of the code makes any bloody
sense. So, I can't fix it.
love to fix it, but the code makes no
sense
whatsoever.
Like, it's like almost perfectly
designed to make my life differentay.
Okay,
let's just fill out and go back to
figuring out what's wrong with the end.
So,
it gets.3 hearts on average.
That definitely doesn't make sense,
right?
Because all you have to do to get those
hearts.
I want to know what does the agents in
your environment do? Like what do they
learn and how can this be beneficial? Uh
in this environment that I'm working on,
I have no idea. It's like
maybe I can show you.
I'll show you quickly on the website.
So it's like this resource conversion
environment where like the agents run
around and convert resources from one
type to another.
Uh, this is like a third party
environment that I'm trying to fix for
authors, but
Are we at That slow SPS? Are you kidding
me?
What is wrong with this environment,
man?
Hang on. Something's not right here.
Yeah,
my CPU hammered or something.
Just that slow.
How can we simulate a real world
scenario and does that even ever happen?
Yeah, of course. So, like what we're
doing here is fundamental RL research,
right? You use RL on simulators that
just it's not a game. Instead, it's like
a driving sim or a drone or a robot or
an industrial process. It's been used in
a ton of different cases. Um, it's just
a heck of a lot easier to do research on
games a lot of the time. They're way
more interpretable, at least when
they're built sely. Um, and there's like
a very long history of AI research being
done on games and then used elsewhere.
We actually have like a basic driving
sim, we've got like this terraforming
sim, and we've got um a drone sim all on
the website now.
Question above from me. How do I explain
batch size param in config for vec
versus batch size in n section.
Um so the one in the n is the number of
I think we did for GPU drive it's the
total number of cars right? So it's the
total number of cars in however many
maps that it takes on one process. And
then the ve is the number of processes.
You can do like 10 24 cars per process
and then eight processes.
This end is freaking molasses is going
on. This is going to drive me insane.
So, we're going to just like But what
this is going to have a mine,
a generator, and unalter.
Then, it's going to be uh
11.
Where is it? By 11
room.
Wait, what? Numb steps
taken. Well, yes, that's technically
could be the same thing,
I think.
Don't tell me this is lower.
No, don't tell me this is lower.
Why? Why is the environment so Huh? Why
is it so?
This is somehow still going to be slow.
Sure.
No,
totally screwed up on my system, you
know, like breakout trains normal.
This is just pathetic how slow this
thing is.
Yeah, I don't know what they've done,
man. It's just like it's a very simple
end. It should run millions. It's just
the code is just bad.
No, it's already at 16 workers. It's
just bad. Like, I'm going to have to go
in and figure it out. And it's like
modern C++ nightmare. So, I don't know
what to
It's like genuinely a cool project as
well. It's just like this like the exact
opposite of how I would build it.
Like I want to help him. It's just it's
very difficult way. The code is
like this is literally at this point
like cuz they've stripped down some of
the mechanics I'm pretty sure in order
to make it like actually work.
This is the type of thing where I could
probably implement this full envir
times this speed like three days tops.
You know, they want all their
This all the ends spikes up and then
spikes down. Word goes up.
Spamming something.
We need to find some setting that's like
faster than this though.
That's a good username.
Explosion fan 44.
I mean this has done decent numbers
here.
Check article.
It cool if you make a LinkedIn page now.
Uh, how hard is it to set that up for a
company?
I got to do this from the other browser.
Hang on.
I guess we'll just make today deal with
all the cursed horrible software and
sites.
Oh, it's 5:37. I got dinner soon. Finish
that.
They have DM'd you. I think I have to
sign into a personal LinkedIn first. Let
me figure out
Wait, how the heck did it I didn't
update this thing. I didn't think
I guess it has my PhD on it
somehow.
What the heck industry is this supposed
to?
Yes
s
let's ask rock
I got to upload the puffer fish. I
should have him on my computer.
There's a puffer.
Look at this. I literally
back.
It's literally dropping my OBS. That's
how dumb this thing is.
I don't know how this is not worth like
zero dollars.
Let me see if I can get this to work
before it literally breaks again.
Oh, it literally is their file browser.
It's that bad.
Crashes your like maximally spec
possible desktop. when you try to upload
a file as a new one.
I don't know how you do that.
The stream is lagging. Are you training?
Nope. That's LinkedIn.
I got to do this and then hopefully
it'll let me upload a logo.
Maybe they have Do we have the
technology? Let's see.
Wait, how do I not It doesn't let me
upload a logo.
Oh no, not this again. There goes the
stream.
This is why I didn't want to do this,
man. Nobody can build software least of
all these guys. It's just like like this
is like okay this is the equivalent of
like if you were to go to a restaurant
right and like you know like and you're
like a chef all right and they serve you
like instant ramen. Okay, that's how I
feel right now seeing this freaking
software
It's going to crash the stream if I hit
Wait, watch this.
Nope.
Literally just nope.
We'll try Firefox.
Where's my uh my company page that I
just made?
Yeah, I will do that. I got to run for
dinner. I'll see I'll message you after.
Uh for folks watching, thanks. There
will be less chaos in the coming days.
Hopefully, we will have some cool RL
again.
All the actually fun stuff's at
puffer.ai.